before i became a character designer
creature makeup designer myself in my
household there were kind of two
um
examples of a
creative
sort of geniuses one of course was dick
smith and the other my father had a
familiarity somehow with uh stop-motion
animator ray harryhausen you know when
you're a little kid
you don't have any idea how any of these
special effects are created but what you
do notice is design
and
what i saw in
harryhausen's work was
fantastical designs non-anthropomorphic
designs because he wasn't dealing with
uh
the constraints of a human body or human
face what i saw in dick smith's work was
reality based
of course because you're dealing with a
human face you have the constraints of
eye spacing mouth placement etc
and it in a way makes the task more
difficult because you have to
pull forth as much imagination as
possible within that somewhat limited
palette
and i think that is
what dick's work always
excelled at was uh his his design sense
he was able to create designs that were
at the same time fanciful and realistic
i i it wasn't until i was a teenager
that i realized that
much of dick's work is invisible in
films and you'll see that tonight in the
exorcist with the uh the father marin
work 50 of the makeup in the in the show
goes unnoticed because it's so effective
he he made max von siedel look them kind
of like he looks now
what dick manages to do is deftly blend
reality and fantasy
and to unsettling effect and
never is it more unsettling than uh in
the reagan makeup what he shows us with
this makeup is the story of the film
which is
a struggle between good and evil
where the battlefield is a young child's
body
when it came out i was in junior high
and there was uh you know everyone was
talking about it reviewers were talking
about it kids were talking about it and
uh kids would say to me hey do you want
to go see it we can sneak in or my big
brother will get you willow what and i
remember thinking screw that this movie
is dangerous
and and it still feels dangerous even
now by today's standards and i think the
reason that it does is that
well of course it's a great film and
it's a team effort right it's it's a
combination of the actor the director
the writer the cinematographer
um
but if it weren't for what dick did if
it weren't for his design
uh
there would be no movie and if you look
at his design
his tests you see that he kind of
explored some more beauty based makeups
before he landed on the iconic raw
psychologically horrifying makeup that
he ended up doing and i think that's
part of
what makes a makeup artist a character
designer great
is that uh he understood the intent of
the film
and he uh doggedly pursued it until he
got us there and the reason that i still
feel the word dangerous comes to my mind
is that uh
is that this film takes you to places
that are not safe
and it is the genius of his design uh
bringing out the story in the face of
the little girl you look at reagan and
you clearly see the story
he subtly has structurally changed her
face to show the evil that's within her
but yet he gives her lacerations and
open sores
that show the toll that it's taking on
her young body so she wasn't she was not
the physical embodiment of a demon she's
a child with a demon inside her an evil
force inside her that is changing her so
you have to feel that there's that the
child is at risk otherwise the movie
doesn't work if she just became a scaly
you know
dare i say it cgi creature you would not
be invested in the film anymore so but i
wanted to say thank you again for
allowing me to be here and thank you
dick for all of your inspirational work
and congratulations everything you
deserve